Partnerships are a great way to maximize
or initiate distribution of your app.
Partnerships can be mutually
beneficial for many companies and
can be cost effective when
you're just starting out.
When thinking about potential partners,
you need to think about touch points,
which are the methods you use
to connect with your customers.
So is it a face to face meeting,
is it through online ads, or
is it through a partnership?
You'll need to figure out
the lifestyle of your customer.
And when they need to solve a problem,
you have the solution for it.
For Embarkment,
our customers will be looking for
a solution to their dog sitting
needs when they are going to travel.
Let's think about the behavior of a
person that goes on vacation, and where
we might find an opportunity to connect
with them, when they need us most.
This person might book his
flight online, maybe search for
a hotel or AirBnB in his destination,
and perhaps also rent a car.
>> For example, we could consider
partnering with a travel agency to be
their preferred dogsitting service.
When booking with a travel agency,
you'll have add-on options,
like renting a car, booking a hotel,
flights, getting travel insurance, and
now we'll pitch them adding dogsitting.
Now we need to consider why somebody
else would want to partner with us.
In this case, we would be great for
a travel agency
because they're now able to offer
a more holistic booking experience and
being the one stop shop for
their customers.
>> More than that,
these players are usually basing
their model on affiliate networks.
So, they get a fee for each click or
conversion coming from
their site to ours.
For us, it's great because they're
putting us in front of people who
are planning to travel, and
we will be paying them only for
a successful outcome.
Either leads, which are clicks.
Or customers, so conversions.
It's a mutually beneficial relationship.
>> Take YouTube, for example.
When they were just starting out they
sought a partnership with Myspace
to host their videos, and
look where YouTube is now.
You're actually watching
a YouTube hosted video right now.
On that note, let's hear from
Steve Chen, a YouTube co-founder.